In Pyongyang, tears for their supreme leader.
North Koreans lined up to mourn the death of Kim Jong Il,...
...laying flowers at a monument to him.
The announcement on North Korean state television...
...sent the world diplomatic community scrambling.
South Korea's president called an emergency national security meeting.
Meanwhile, news of Kim's death sparked up protests on the streets of Seoul,...
With some carrying signs reading "Let's bring reunification."
In Japan, a measured response from Chief Cabinet Secretary Osamu Fujimura.
"We hope that this sudden incident...
...will not negatively affect peace and stability in the Korean peninsula." he says.
The same from Australia's Foreign Minister Kevin Rudd.
"We need to ensure that calm and restraint are exercised...
...at an exceptionally difficult period of transition."
China's Ministry of Foreign Affairs Spokesman Liu Weimin...
...called Kim a great leader of the North Korean people...
...and an intimate friend of the Chinese people.
In the US, a much less friendly response from congressman Peter King,...
...Chairman of the House Homeland Security Committee.
North Korea is basically an organized crime family posing as a government.
Kim Jong Il was a madman and a tyrant.
His son Kim Jong Un, you have to assume,...
...is cut from the same cloth and will be the same type of leader.
The White House would only say officials are monitoring the situation closely...
...and staying in contact with South Korea.
As the North Korean government calls on the public...
...to embrace Kim's successor Kim Jong Un,...
...the rest of the world is asking one question,...